2021 con una sola moneda en circulación
desde el primero de enero cuba eliminará
el peso convertibles que se cotizaba a
un dólar y dejará solo el peso cubano a
una tasa oficial única de 24 pesos por
dólar la medida largamente esperada
supone la primera devaluación de la
moneda desde la revolución de 1959
aunque menos severa de lo que se temía
así el gobierno busca simplificar el
sistema monetario y cambiario y generar
mejores condiciones comerciales para
impulsar la golpeada economía de la isla
ya se ha expresado que la tarea
ordenamiento no constituye por sí misma
la solución mágica a todos los problemas
presentes en nuestra economía
sin embargo favorecerá la creación de
las condiciones necesarias para avanzar
de manera más sólida
el principal temor frente a la reforma
que se dispare la inflación
aunque el gobierno garantizó que habrá
medidas de contención para evitar los
precios abusivos y sanciones severas
para quienes incumplan pese a que
tendrán seis meses para cambiar sus
pesos convertibles los cubanos se
formaron largas filas para comenzar ese
proceso el anuncio del gobierno trajo
reacciones mixtas a el lugar que ésta
acepta una moneda del lugar que aceptan
otras pienso que a tener una sola moneda
o hacer más aparte elevar a todo el
mundo que está se afanen mal a mamá
por qué
suben los salarios pero en realidad
si todo sube ya vimos los precios de la
corriente que son impagables
y la calidad de vida va a disminuir cada
vez más para amortiguar el impacto la
reforma monetaria incluirá la
quintuplicación del salario mínimo que
pasará de 1787 dólares
el ajuste de las pensiones y la
eliminación de subsidios excesivos y
gratuidades indebidas